hey gamers let's talk strange brigade I
describe what we've played of the game
so far as a classic archeology adventure
themed shooter you can tackle levels
with up to four players a Wayfinder
engineer scholar and soldier most of the
combat came down to horde management
through shooting and triggering traps
followed by identifying the special
mummy causing minions to spawn and
taking it out the puzzles we saw mostly
just involved shooting hieroglyphs in
order to open doors and some doors could
only be opened by specific characters
the game was a bit rough around the
edges with issues like characters doing
melee attacks in the direction of the
character model and not the camera
causing you to lunge awkwardly in the
wrong direction at times but I am a
sucker for co-op and games like this
might be fun when you just want to kick
back and not think too hard at the end
of your work day how do you feel about
games at the end of your work day do you
want a hard challenge or something more
like this title shaping up to be let me
know in the comments below and likes and
subs are always appreciated thanks
everyone
let's get to it hello this chaps up to
no good I'll wager
[Applause]
[Applause]
those rooms look interesting
[Music]
with the puzzle sold our brave chaps
moved on
[Music]
ha
[Music]
beggars
[Applause]
the undiscovered country from which no
traveler returns
ignited a chap didn't take death lying
down
say these ugly look like they new
business stand strange brigade
the Empire is short another brave hero
alas
the veritable stampede of the blighters
instead
[Music]
is it cut news for the spring brigade
will they make some corner of a foreign
tune forever England or will they
survive to fight another day
tune in next week to find out in another
gripping installment of the strange
brigade
[Music]